[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt auch mal auf den Server
Minecraft loser part 2
was denn du hier concrafter abgebaut
ja
[Musik]
genau
und dann werde ich die auch noch mal ein
paar Fackeln geben damit du einfach so
ein paar andere Hand hast hier
wussten die Fackel was krass schon
aufgenommen wie geht man noch mal rein
zum Schlafen was denkst du denn
[Musik]
egal ich crafte die Tür ab
einfacher als jetzt nachzufragen
Rechtsklick ich habe kein Rechtsklick
irgendwie
wie machst du das denn wenn du sonst
recht sie drücken musst
ich habe auch aus Versehen das Bett
weggekraftet kannst du es wieder
herstellen
einfach dann kommt das wieder
in der Hand du hast auch eine Schaufel
in der Hand gut mein Fehler
ja okay du musst halt rechts die drücken
ne okay hier schreibt jemand Rechtsklick
auf MacBook ist mit beiden Fingern
klicken schmeiß mir das Bett zu dann
stelle ich es auf jeden Fall erstmal hin
wie schmeißt man noch dazu
[Musik]
jetzt hast du es wieder selber
aufgenommen
Minecraft gebaut um schlafen zu gehen
[Musik]
Alter aufgenommen ich rasch komplett aus
und jetzt Rechtsklick aufs Bett
[Musik]
jetzt erstmal wieder die Tür hier rein
Sandra
hier
hinten hier hinten hast
du hin
hier hast du die Tür geklaut oder wie ja
und da quasi jetzt einfach auf Kuh nein
mit Kuh wirst du etwas ja weg du musst
Rechtsklick auf den auf den Boden damit
machen ja
bei kann man sich rein theoretisch den
Kölner Dom auch craften theoretisch ja
aber da brauchst du halt viele Items für
ne Mist
[Musik]
was machst du dicker
hallo manchmal habe ich Schiss vor der
lol was ist das denn komm mal zu mir
rüber
ah guck mal das hast du schlau gemacht
also hier geht's irgendwie runter so
eine Höhle glaube ich
[Musik]
mein halbes Leben ist schon weg komisch
sanitätermodus Luca wie komme ich hier
hoch warte ich komme zu dir ich habe
eine Idee haben einmal ich lass jetzt
Wasser runter dann komme ich zu dir
hallo hallo Sandra wir müssen raus
[Musik]
jetzt auf den Block den ich gerade
gesetzt habe
jetzt hüpfst du mit mir drauf wieder
[Musik]
ein bisschen weiter zu mir kommen
jetzt kannst du hier über eine Treppe
hochlaufen
bitte schön danke dir Bro Holzhacken ne
ja gerne Holz eisenspitzhacke benutzen
irgendwie habe ich ganze Zeit Streit mit
den Schweinen hey du scheiß Schwein
grundsätzlich nicht an wie kannst du den
Stress mit Schweinen haben Alter
hast du Hunger unten rechts was sagen da
deine Hunger und mein Herr mein Herz ist
gleich tot hier nimm das mal ist mal die
ganzen Äpfel die dann kannst du rechts
gedrückt halten Luca ich krieg von
Äpfeln kriege ich heftige Blähungen ja
dann aber das ist Minecraft
zusammenwohnen deswegen werden wir uns
jetzt zwei verschiedene Häuser bauen
aber naja jeder wie am Markt ey pass mal
auf du fängst schon ne
nur wenige Minuten später fertig
[Musik]
wie findest du es von der Skala von 1
bis 10 für mein erstes Haus des clash of
change
in the dark of the night vier mal Nein
Luca kannst du mir dann gleich mal
helfen mit meinem Dach Luca
ten
Dach löschen
dein Ernst das war dein Haus gesehen
also du sagst das schrecklichste an dem
Haus ist das Dach ja du Bastard warum
vorne ist es voll komisch das geht so
nach vorne jetzt habe ich extra gemacht
für was sieht das aus wie ein Elefanten
Gesicht
guck mal von hier
ach du scheiße lass uns schnell weg ich
kann mir die Tragödie nicht angucken
auf jeden Fall nein
[Musik]
ist das ein Stück vom Haus was hier
irgendwie aus Versehen
irgendwie drin gelandet ist oder was ist
das Schiff das ist ein Schiff das ist
eine Kiste in dem Teil unter dem Wasser
sollte die Kiste sein da drunter wird
das irgendwo sein hier der Loot glaube
ich
oh nein
ah Lederjacke Bambus boah wenn ich jetzt
zum Setzling drin gewesen wäre wäre
krass gewesen zwei Personen sitzen ja
aber ich will nicht mit Sandra sitzen
dann gehen wir unterhalten
glitzerndes Oberteil Ansager
aus ne sehr gut
[Musik]
eine Ewigkeit später
schlag ihn
komm runter komm ich rufe Dich mal bei
Facetime an zeig mal eben bei Facetime
hier wo du bist meinst du du findest den
Ort wieder wo wir uns getrennt haben wo
wir geschlafen haben
niemals
bleibt da mal stehen ich habe eine Idee
drück mal
bei deinem Mac FN gedrückt halten und F3
sind jetzt ganz viele Zahlen
eingeblendet genau ja schick mir mal ein
Foto von diesen Zahlen bei Whatsapp nur
wenige Minuten später das hat seine mir
gerade geschickt
[Musik]
völlig weit weg
alter Schwede ja
ich springe Luca ach Baby endlich
keine Ahnung oh endlich ey wir können
schlafen geil für die nächste Folge für
die nächsten Livestream hier Minecraft
ich setze uns hier Blöcke hin damit wir
wissen dass wir in diese Richtung da
laufen müssen zum nächsten Mal an der
Stelle würden wir allerdings diesen
Minecraft Livestream jetzt auch beenden
Sandy danke dass du mit dabei was sie
wieder ne
ja es war zu viel
okay sondern entwickelt sich hier zum
Roboter und an der Stelle ist dann nicht
nur logischerweise auch der Livestream
vorbei sondern auch dieses Highlight
Stream best of Youtube Video Minecraft
loser part 2 sondern Luca spielen
Multiplayer extrem langer Name wenn ihr
in Zukunft bei den Stream dabei sein
wollt Leute
twitch.tv/laser Luca oder einfach deine
Suche dort Laserdrucker eingeben könnt
ihr mir dort Folgen kostenlos Seite mit
dabei ich weiß nicht mal live oder so
folgt mir einfach macht er die
Benachrichtigung an dann bekommt ihr
eine Push Benachrichtigung auf Handy
wenn ich live bin und dann könnt ihr
dann noch mehr live dabei zu gucken wie
wir in Minecraft versuchen klar zu
kommen also wenn es euch gefallen hat
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und Klick auf
die Glocke wir sehen uns die Tage wieder
in einem neuen Video haut rein macht's
ciao